♪ ♪
>> Tucker: DR. ANTHONY FAUCI
HAS DONE MORE THAN ANY OTHER
AMERICAN OFFICIAL TO PROMOTE
LONG-TERM NATIONWIDE QUARANTINE,
THE LOCKDOWN THAT’S DESTROYING
OUR ECONOMY.
FAUCI SUGGESTED HANDSHAKES
SHOULD GO AWAY FOREVER, HE TOLD
CONGRESS THAT REOPENING SCHOOLS
NEXT FALL MIGHT BE A BAD IDEA.
THEN TODAY, HE SEEMED TO WOBBLE.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID WITH AN
INTERVIEW WITH CNBC.
>> WE CAN’T STAY LOCKED DOWN FOR
SUCH A CONSIDERABLE PERIOD OF
TIME THAT YOU MIGHT DO
IRREPARABLE DAMAGE AND HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
INCLUDING CONSEQUENCES FOR
HEALTH.
>> Tucker: IRREPARABLE DAMAGE,
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES?
IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN NICE TO HEAR
A LITTLE BIT MORE OF THAT MONTHS
AGO WHEN IT ACTUALLY MATTERED.
BACK WHEN DOCTORS WERE BEING
KICKED OFF OF YOUTUBE FOR SAYING
EXACTLY THE SAME THING.
BARSTOOL SPORTS PRESIDENT DAVE
PORTNOY NOTICED AND HAD THESE
THOUGHTS.
>> THIS IS MY WHOLE POINT, I
JUST DID A BRAND THAT WENT VIRAL
LAST WEEK BECAUSE YOU’RE LIKE IF
WE OPEN UP THE COUNTRY,
EVERYONE’S GOING TO [BLEEP] DIE.
NOW I PUT A LITTLE HEAT ON HIM
AND NOW THE WIND BLOWS AND HE’S
LIKE WE CAN’T STAY IN FOREVER,
IT CAUSES IRREPARABLE DAMAGE,
WHAT IS IT?
PICK UP [BLEEP] SIDE OR AT LEAST
SAY YOU DON’T KNOW WHAT YOU’RE
[BLEEP] TALKING ABOUT.
IF NOBODY KNOWS ANYTHING, THEN
WHAT THE [BLEEP] ARE WE DOING?
>> Tucker: HE’S BEEN LOCKED
INDOORS FOR A COUPLE MONTHS IN
NEW YORK CITY, HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
NICELY PUT.
YOU’RE SITTING AT HOME, YOUR
MONITORING THIS, YOU HAVE A
SPECIAL INTEREST BECAUSE YOU’RE
QUARANTINED YOURSELF, WHAT DID
YOU MAKE OF WHAT HE SAID TO?
>> I WAS TAKEN OFF GUARD, I’VE
ESCAPED TO NANTUCKET BECAUSE
THAT’S WHY THEY DIDN’T HAVE THE
SUIT AND TIE.
I THOUGHT I WAS TAKING CRAZY
PILLS.
I DON’T MEAN TO PILE ON FAUCI
BUT WE ARE MAKING VERY IMPORTANT
DECISIONS BASED ON WHAT HE’S
SAYING AND I THINK IT’S OKAY TO
SAY I REALLY DON’T KNOW.
BUT I GET THE FEELING IF YOU
ASKED HIM THIS QUESTION, WHAT
DOES ONE PLUS ONE EQUAL, YOU’RE
GOING TO GET SEVEN DIFFERENT
ANSWERS.
IT’S OKAY TO SAY YOU DON’T KNOW,
THAT’S KIND OF MY POINT.
I DON’T THINK ANYBODY KNOWS THE
TRUE ANSWERS.
IT’S A MOVING TARGET, IT’S A
DISEASE WE NEVER MET WITH BEFORE
BUT THAT’S WHY I THINK AT THIS
POINT YOU LET PEOPLE,
INDIVIDUALS MAKE DECISIONS
THEMSELVES.
THE ONLY THING AS I SAID BEFORE
THAT WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN IS IF
YOU CONTINUE THE QUARANTINE,
TONS OF PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LOSE
THEIR LIVELIHOODS.
OF THOSE PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE THE
CHOICE TO MAKE THE DECISION
RATHER THAN DEPEND ON THINGS --
LISTEN, FAUCI MAY BE THE NICEST
GUY IN THE WORLD BUT HE SAID
WEAR MASKS, DON’T WEAR MASKS.
HE SAID THE LOCKDOWN MAY GO ON
INDEFINITELY, WE HAVE TO END THE
LOCKDOWN.
IT’S TOUGH TO PUT THAT MUCH
STAKE IN WHAT HE’S SAYING.
MAYBE TRUMP GOT HIM IN A ROOM
AND SHOOK HIM AND SAID TODAY YOU
SAY THIS -- IT’S TOUGH TO TAKE
THEM SERIOUSLY WHEN YOU
LITERALLY SAY THE EXACT OPPOSITE
AND WE’RE NOT TALKING MONTHS, WE
ARE TALKING DAYS APART, WHAT
CHANGED?
>> Tucker: I THINK YOUR POINT
ABOUT NOT KNOWING WHAT THE TRUTH
IS IS ABSENTLY FAIR AND
IMPORTANT AND I’VE BEEN WRONG ON
THIS SHOW A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
TIMES BUT I ADMIT IT BECAUSE I
KNOW PEOPLE HAVE YOUTUBE AND
THEY CAN CHECK.
FAUCI COMES ON AND ACTS LIKE
HE’S ALWAYS BEEN SAYING THIS 12
DAYS AGO HE’S BEEN SAYING THE
OPPOSITE, SHOULDN’T HE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CHANGE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ANY POLITICIAN OR ANYBODY IN
GENERAL, I WOULD MUCH PREFER
SOMEBODY -- FIRST OF ALL, I HAVE
NO PROBLEM SAYING I DON’T KNOW.
IF YOU HAVE A STRONG OPINION,
SAY IT AND IF YOU’RE WRONG, THEN
SAY HANDS UP, I’M THE FIRST ONE,
WHEN I MAKE A MISTAKE, AMERICAN
PEOPLE APPRECIATE THAT.
I INVESTED IN CHINESE COMPANY
THAT PROBABLY HATES ME FOR IT, I
MADE THE WRONG MOVE.
YOU HAVE TO SAY IT, OWN UP TO
IT, NO ONE IS EXPECTING ANY
HUMAN BEING TO BE PERFECT.
WHEN YOU SAY AT A VERY IMPORTANT
STATEMENT AND ACT LIKE IT NEVER
HAPPENED AT SAY SOMETHING
DIFFERENT, I’M LIKE WHAT IS HE
DOING?
I DON’T KNOW IF HE IS DOING IT
INTENTIONALLY BUT EITHER TAKE A
CIDER SAY I DON’T KNOW AND
ACKNOWLEDGE WHEN YOU MAKE A
MISTAKE.
RIGHT NOW, I DON’T TRUST WHAT HE
SAYS, I DON’T KNOW HOW ANYBODY
COULD DO.
I DON’T KNOW IF IT’S
INTENTIONAL, I JUST HONESTLY
THINK THIS THING MOVES.
THERE IS VIDEOS OF FAUCI ALL
THROUGH THIS, HE’S ON DIFFERENT
SIDES DEPENDING ON THE DAY,
DEPENDING ON THE MOOD, WE ARE
MAKING SEEMINGLY LIFE-CHANGING
DECISIONS FOR OTHER PEOPLE BASED
ON FACTS THAT ARE CLEARLY NOT
FACTS.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
YESTERDAY, FAUCI DID AN
INTERVIEW WITH JULIA ROBERTS,
NOT THE JOURNALIST BUT THE
ACTRESS.
DOES THAT MAKE YOU TRUST HIM
MORE OR LESS?
>> I MEAN, THERE’S AN ELEMENT
THAT YOU WANT YOUR LEAD DOCTOR
NOT GOING TO A HOLLYWOOD STARLET
BUT HE’S GOT A BELIEVABLE FACE.
IF YOU PUT HIM IN FRONT OF ME I
WOULD BE LIKE THAT I TRUST HIM,
HE LOOKED SMART.
BUT I’M PAYING ATTENTION TO THE
WORDS.
I LIKE A PRETTY WOMAN AS THE
NEXT GUY SO I’M NOT HOLDING THAT
AGAINST HIM.
>> Tucker: I TOTALLY AGREE
ABOUT THE WAY HE LOOKS.
WHEN I SEE FAUCI ON TV WITH THE
SOUND OFF I THINK I BELIEVE THAT
GUY.
WE’VE INTERVIEWED HIM ON THE
SHOW, IT’S NOTHING PERSONAL BUT
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE LISTENED SO
LONG BECAUSE HE LOOKS LIKE A GUY
YOU WOULD LISTEN TO.
>> HE ABSOLUTELY LOOKS LIKE AN
EXPERT AND TO BE HONEST, EVERY
SINGLE QUESTION OR SPEECH, HE
SOUNDS LIKE AN EXPERT.
I’M LIKE OKAY, I WILL LISTEN AND
I BELIEVE BUT NOW THERE’S GOOD
ENOUGH FOOTAGE, THEY ARE HANGING
ON WHAT HE SAYS.
WHEN HE GOES IN FRONT OF THE
SENATE AND SAYS IF WE OPEN TOO
QUICKLY THERE IS GOING TO BE
MASSIVE DAMAGE AND DEATH, THOSE
ARE HEAVY WORDS TO THEN GO SEE
THE EXACT OPPOSITE A WEEK LATER,
IT’S ALMOST THE GRAVITY OF WHAT
HE SAYS IN THE MOMENT, IT’S
ALMOST LIKE HE’S LOSING.
BE VERY CAREFUL WITH THE WORDS,
BECAUSE WHAT HE SAYS I FEEL LIKE
IS WHAT A LOT OF STATES ARE
BASING THEIR REOPENING ON.
WHAT A MODEL, IT’S ALWAYS A
MOVING TARGET AND WHAT WE HAVE
TO REMEMBER IS, I DON’T THINK
ANYONE KNOWS THE ANSWER.
IT’S TOUGH TO TELL A BUSINESS
OWNER, YOU’RE GOING TO LOSE YOUR
BUSINESS BECAUSE OF WHAT FAUCI
SAID IN THE GUY IS LIKE AT WHAT
POINT, WHAT YARDSTICK ARE WE
USING?
>> Tucker: I THINK AT THIS
POINT I TRUST JULIA ROBERTS
MORE.
>> SHE’S VERY BELIEVABLE, SHE’S
A VERY BELIEVABLE AMERICAN.